Will Arnett here with some huge news. Look, everyone knows the world of soccer has hundreds of leagues and competitions and, et cetera. But there's one that stands above them all, the Champions League. Oh, champions! You know, that's better than... Anyway, join our newest Smartless Media podcast called Goaless,
我是威尔·阿奈特，带给您一些重大消息。听着，大家都知道足球世界有成百上千的联赛和比赛等等，但有一个凌驾于所有之上，那就是欧冠。哦，冠军！你知道，这比……不管怎样，欢迎收听我们由 Smartless Media 推出的最新播客《Goaless》，
where the hilarious and football-obsessed British comedian Russell Howard partners up with soccer-obsessed Champions League announcer Chris Whittingham to highlight the passion, personalities and on-pitch drama that make soccer beautiful and hilarious. Built by fans for fans. So whether you're a fan of Liverpool, like you should be,
由搞笑且痴迷足球的英国喜剧演员拉塞尔·霍华德与痴迷足球的欧冠解说员克里斯·威廷汉姆搭档，带您领略足球运动的美妙与爆笑，感受其中的激情、个性和球场戏剧性。由球迷为球迷打造。所以无论你是利物浦的球迷，正如你理应如此的那样，
Bayern Munich, Real Madrid, or Young Boys, no, no, which is an actual Swiss team called Young Boys, that's their name. We have got you covered. Every Monday and Thursday, the guys kick around the biggest stories from the Champions League, featuring analysis and laughs and stars
拜仁慕尼黑、皇家马德里，还是年轻人队——不不，年轻人队是一支真正的瑞士球队，名字就叫年轻人队。我们都为您全盘涵盖。每周一和周四，两人将畅聊欧冠赛场上的重大故事，并带来精彩的专业分析、欢笑以及热爱这项运动的球星们。
who love the game. What's the goal? You tell us. But why should you listen to me? I'll hand it over to the experts. Here's the show trailer. Hello, I'm Chris Whittingham. I'm a commentator for CBS and Paramount Plus
我们的目标是什么？你来告诉我们。但你为什么要听我废话呢？我把它交给专家们吧。下面是节目预告。大家好，我是克里斯·威廷汉姆。我是 CBS 和派拉蒙+
on the UEFA Champions League. And I'm Russell Howard, a stand-up comedian from Great Britain. Welcome to Goalus of all the unimportant things in life. We're here for the most important football. He means soccer. Each week we'll kick around the biggest stories, predictions and results from the Champions League. We'll talk with players, comedians, and actors
欧洲冠军联赛的评论员。我是拉塞尔·霍华德，一名来自英国的单口喜剧演员。欢迎来到《Goaless》。在生活中所有不重要的事物中，我们专为最重要的事情而来——足球。他说的是美式橄榄球（soccer）。每周我们都会畅聊欧冠赛场上的重磅故事、预测和赛果。我们将与球员、喜剧演员和演员对话，
who share our love and passion for the game, plus news from the wider world of soccer. It's football! For the best goals to the funniest player trolls, disastrous decisions to disastrous haircuts, goalless is your new favorite football show by fans for fans. Well, okay, actually, I do have a slight history lesson for you here.
他们与我们一样对这项运动充满热爱，此外还有更广阔足球世界的动态。这就是足球！从最精彩的进球到最搞笑的球员吐槽，从灾难性的判罚到灾难性的发型，《Goaless》由球迷为球迷打造，是你最喜爱的新足球节目。好吧，其实关于这个词，我确实要给你上一课。
Okay, okay. The word soccer is actually an English word. If you go back down the years, you watch some BBC broadcasts in the 1970s, 1980s, they're calling it soccer. Things evolve, my friend. We need a new word specifically for the podcast so that we can get through it. How about ffucker?
好吧，好吧。其实“soccer”是个地道的英国词。如果你回溯过去，看一些 20世纪 70、80 年代的 BBC 转播，他们当时就叫它 soccer。事物总是在演变的，我的朋友。我们需要为这个播客专门造个新词，这样我们才能顺利讲下去。叫 ffucker 怎么样？
Sock ball. Sockball? That could work. Sockball? That's not it. Now, Russell, one of the biggest things for viewers to get used to in this year's Champions League is it's a completely different format. One 36 team league table where not everyone is playing each other home and away, eight different opponents for every team.
Sock ball 怎么样。Sockball？这倒行得通。Sockball？好像不对。话说回来，拉塞尔，今年欧冠让观众们最需要适应的一点，就是它完全不同的赛制。一个拥有 36 支球队的单一积分榜，大家不再是主客场双循环交手，每支球队将面对 8 个不同的对手。
Realistically, I think the biggest thing for viewers to get. used to is that every week they're going to be games between big teams. And that used to not be the case. If you're not watching your own team, you're going to watch whatever the biggest game is and there will be one of those almost every single day of this league state. That's a really good point actually, in it? Because it means we don't have to wait to the quarterfinals for those kind of red hot games. So the fact that Liverpool, like we've got Real Madrid, so already, I'm so excited the idea that Bellingham and Bappe, Venetius Jr., I'll get to see them live. I met Bellingham. How cool is this, right? Okay. It was such an insane moment. He saw me at
说实话，我觉得观众们最需要适应的，是每周都会有强强对话。以前可不是这样的。如果你不看自己支持的球队，你也会去看最重磅的比赛，而在这个联赛阶段，几乎每天都会有一场这样的比赛。这其实是个很好的观点，不是吗？因为这意味着我们不必等到四分之一决赛才能看到那种火爆的比赛。所以利物浦将对阵皇马这样的事实，让我现在就无比兴奋，一想到贝林厄姆、姆巴佩、维尼修斯 Jr，我就能看他们的现场比赛。我遇到过贝林厄姆。这有多酷，对吧？好吧。当时太疯狂了。他在
Heathrow Airport and he asked me for a photo because when he was young, he was a fan of my TV show. And it just blew my mind. But my phone was going through the security so I didn't get the opportunity to also have my photo with Jude Bellingham. So I told my friends and none of them believe me. So you've got to get in touch with Jude Bellingham to get that picture off him. Yeah. But it was, I You know, one of those moments where you meet somebody so impressive and it just happens in a kind of a blur. And I kind of got very formal. And when I met his mom, I was like, you know, I think I said. Mrs. Bellingham, lovely to meet you?
希思罗机场看到了我，还找我合影，因为他年轻时是我的电视节目的粉丝。这让我简直惊呆了。但当时我的手机正在过安检，所以我错失了和裘德·贝林厄姆合影的机会。我把这事告诉了朋友们，结果他们谁都不信。所以你得联系一下裘德·贝林厄姆，把那张照片要回来。对。不过那真是一个……你知道的，那种你遇到了一个极其优秀的人，而整个过程就像过电影一样模糊的时刻。我当时变得非常拘谨。当我遇到他妈妈时，我想我大概说过：贝林厄姆夫人，很高兴见到您？
I think I did. I went, Mrs. Bellingham, your son is an absolutely phenomenal footballer. You should be very proud. I kind of, maybe that's what ruined it. Maybe he was like, I think he's cracking onto my mom, which I wasn't in any way. Any football who would you like to meet? Zlatan. I would kind of love to meet Zlatan, even.
我想我确实这么说了。我说，贝林厄姆夫人，您的儿子是一位绝对现象级的球星。您应该为他感到骄傲。我当时……也许这就是把事情搞砸的原因吧。也许他在想，这老小子是在对准我妈献殷勤吗？我可完全没那个意思。说到足球运动员，你最想见谁？伊布。其实我挺想见伊布的，哪怕
even though he would absolutely overwhelm. I work for our Syria coverage at Paramount Plus. And he went up to the desk and straightaway was like, oh, this is the B team. What happened to the A team that does the Champions League? And it was like, just what an absolute savage this man is. I don't know if I could really speak to him. Yeah.
哪怕他绝对会给人带来极大的压迫感。我为派拉蒙+的意甲转播工作，他走到直播台前直接就说：“哦，这是B队啊。做欧冠节目的A队去哪了？”这人简直是个不折不扣的狠角色。我不知道自己能不能真正跟他对话。是的。
It would be weird. He's a terrifying guy. He's really funny as well. And he also has the look of a man who could break into a zoo and fight a gorilla. Do you know what I mean? Like, he's... Well, okay, he could talk his way into doing that. and then probably not farewell against the gorilla, I would imagine.
那会很诡异。他是个吓人的一伙计。但他其实也挺搞笑的。而且他身上有一种男人的气质，感觉能闯进动物园跟大猩猩打一架。你明白我的意思吗？就像他……好吧，他也许能凭三寸不烂之舌说服别人让他进去，然后面对大猩猩时可能就没那么好运了，我猜。
Again, it's a challenge. So we need to get a photo from Jude Bellingham, and we need to find a way Slater. He's not busy, he's not playing. Let's get him into a zoo. Let's get the right gorilla, and let's make that happen. Ricardo Califiori stole Europe's hearts this summer because of his wonderful haircut.
总之，这是一个挑战。所以我们需要从裘德·贝林厄姆那里弄张照片，还得想办法找个伊布。他反正闲着，也没比赛踢。咱们把他弄进动物园，找一只合适的大猩猩，把这事儿办成。里卡多·卡拉菲奥里今年夏天凭借他那完美的飘逸发型偷走了全欧洲球迷的心。
The Italians usually bring the hair to the competition. Germans as well. Do you feel like we will have better hair, style in the Champions League because it's Italy and Germany, maybe not England that is getting the extra spot in the Champions League. Do you know, I've never thought about the locks of my nation, but you're right, I think, yeah, Italian men have the best hair. Go down the ears, Pierlo, Nesta, Maldini.
意大利人通常能把好发型带到比赛中。德国人也一样。你觉得我们在欧冠里会不会拥有更好的发型和时尚感，因为意大利和德国（或许不是英格兰，英格兰在欧冠多了一个名额）进来了？你知道吗，我从来没想过我们国家的头发水平，但你是对的，我觉得吧，意大利男人确实留着最好的发型。细数过去，皮尔洛、内斯塔、马尔蒂尼。
And now, I mean, Califiori, if you had said to Arsenal fans before the Euros, hey, we're going to sign Ricardo Califiori in the, you wouldn't have heard of him. But all of a sudden you see his hair and you think, This is the best defender that we've ever seen. Our teeth are bad. That's what the English are known for. We have bad teeth.
还有现在，我是说，卡拉菲奥里，如果在欧洲杯之前你对阿森纳球迷说，嘿，我们要签下里卡多·卡拉菲奥里，你当时根本没听说过他。但突然之间你看到他的发型，就会觉得：这是我们见过的最强后卫。我们的牙齿不好。这就是英国人出名的原因。我们牙齿不好。
But is it our hair as well? Is that what America thinks of us, that we have bad hair? Jack Grinish. Jack Grinish is good hair. Jack Grilish is wonderful hair. Wonderful hair. But also, I do think Wayne Rooney was not the best diplomat in this regard. Yeah, he's probably fair.
但难道我们的头发也不行吗？美国人就是这么看我们的，觉得我们连头发都不好吗？杰克·格拉利什。杰克·格拉利什的头发很好。杰克·格拉利什有一头绝妙的头发。绝妙的头发。不过话说回来，我觉得韦恩·鲁尼在这方面确实算不上最好的外交官。是的，这倒挺中肯的。
I was just thinking then some of our great footballers, except for Beckham, do look like they were kind of something happened in the laboratory with a potato. From Smartless Media, Meadowlark, Sirius, and Paramount Plus, listen to Goaless wherever you get your podcasts. The first episode premieres on September the 19th. Don't forget to follow Goaless for new episodes right when they drop and join us on social at Goaless the show. You can listen to Golless anywhere you get your podcasts. Whether you're a longtime fan or new to the sport, Gollis is the place to go to get information and have some laughs, which is nice for everybody. So what are you waiting for?
我刚才还在想，我们的一些伟大球星，除了贝克汉姆之外，看起来都长得像是实验室里拿土豆做实验失败的产物。来自 Smartless Media、Meadowlark、Sirius 和 Paramount Plus，在您获取播客的任何地方收听《Goaless》。首集将于 9 月 19 日首播。别忘了关注《Goaless》以便在每集上线时第一时间收听，并在社交媒体上关注我们 @Goaless the show。您可以在任何收听播客的地方收听《Goaless》。无论您是老球迷还是这项运动的新手，《Goaless》都是您获取资讯、收获欢笑的好去处，这对每个人来说都很棒。还在等什么？
Go and give Goallis a follow. Golless is proudly sponsored by Paramount Plus, the home of the UEFA Champions League. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
快去关注《Goaless》吧。《Goaless》由欧洲冠军联赛的主场派拉蒙+自豪赞助。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。